hall on the web at stroudhall.com
robert steffen a russian military
specialist for the cia
documents soviet counterintelligence
against the nazis during world war
ii in his new book stalin's secret war
the program's 45 minutes
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the national archives
my name is sam anthony and i'm your host
for tonight's lecture in book signing
we are honored to have with us dr robert
stefan
as he will discuss his book stalin's
secret war
soviet counter intelligence against the
nazis 1941-1945
a few points before we begin copies of
the book are available for sale
following our lecture we will have time
for questions and answers with the
audience
and then we'll conclude at the top of
the hour with our book signing
if you have any questions about the
national archives please don't hesitate
to come see me
i'll be glad to tell you about the
national archives its public programs
and our exhibits
bob steffen is no stranger to the
national archives when i look over his
biography it is an impressive one he
served
with the united states air force for 20
years 11 of those on active duty
with the united states air force
security service and the united states
air force electronic security command
he also served for many years in the
united states air force reserve
from 1981 to 1984 dr stefan was in the
library of congress as a soviet
military analyst with the federal
research division
from 1984 to 1987 he was a
counterintelligence analyst with the
defense
intelligence agency and from 1987 until
the present he is with sever he has
served on several
counterintelligence assignments with the
central intelligence agency
bob stephen as i said is no stranger to
the national archives as he used
many of our record groups including
records of the state department and
others and so can you
the national archives task is to
preserve and make accessible
the permanently valuable records of the
federal government currently the number
stands at around 76 billion records
including the declaration constitution
and bill of rights you we have on
displaying our rotunda
but there's so much more and if after
reading the book or
hearing tonight's lecture you want to
learn more please come to the national
archives
with 32 facilities around the country
including the presidential library
system and the federal record centers
i bet there's probably something for you
dr stefan earned his bachelor of arts
from the university of maryland
his master's in international affairs
from american university
and his phd in modern russian and soviet
history from the george washington
university
ladies and gentlemen it gives me great
pleasure to introduce you the author
of stalin's secret war dr robert steffen
well thank you very much sam for that
excellent introduction
ladies and gentlemen it is an honor for
me to be here tonight and i would like
to thank the national archives for
hosting this event
as well as c-span for coming out as well
as the staff of the university presa
kansas for setting this event up
let me start by saying that the book we
are going to discuss tonight
could not have been written without the
help of the dedicated archivists i've
worked with over the years
the wealth of information in this
institution is nothing short of
impressive and with 76 billion records
you can see why
it is without a doubt one of the most
important institutions in the world for
preserving history
and i also very much like to thank all
of you for coming out tonight especially
on a weeknight
to listen to my presentation now this
book stalin's secret war
attempts to lay out what we know about
soviet counterintelligence effort in
world war
ii how it defeated the german
intelligence services
and its impact on german military
operational decision making
and why did i write the book now largely
for
two main reasons one is is to show
how the soviets elevated
counterintelligence from what is
normally viewed by most people i think
is a defensive activity
to a strategic weapon and also to
stimulate
research on combat counter intelligence
and its effect on military operations
now a war in which anywhere from one
hundred and seventy five thousand to
three hundred agents
and two hundred and eighty eighteen
radio playbacks were used can no longer
be ignored
now these agents there's a wide variety
of types of agents but these agents were
virtually all soviet citizens
most of them were prisoners of war they
included line crossers with as little as
one day of training
to agents with six months of training
before being dropped behind enemy lines
now radio playbacks basically use turned
agent radios to transmit controlled
information to the enemy and i'll go
into terminology here in a minute
now in short i wanted to show how the
russians accomplished over two thousand
mile front and four years of sustained
combat
what the british on a smaller scale did
with their double cross system
now the soviet shut down german
clandestine human collection
doubled many of the captured agents fed
the enemy disinformation through those
agents
and that process substantially increase
the effectiveness of soviet military
deception operations
which in turn in my opinion accelerated
the german defeat in the east
now first before we go on since i'll use
a lot of these terms and i want to make
sure everybody understands
what i'm talking about some quick notes
on terminology now counter intelligence
is about two thousand definitions of
counter intelligence but i'll give you
mine and it's a quick one
it is the collection analysis and
exploitation of information
on the activities and operations of
foreign intelligence services
in order to recruit foreign intelligence
officers and detect or neutralize their
operations
now an agent now there's a lot of
misinformation out there about what an
agent is but an agent is someone who is
working with a foreign intelligence
service
usually in a non-officially sanctioned
clandestine relationship
so you hear the term cia agent doesn't
really mean agent they usually meet a
cia staff officer
now whereas a double agent and there's
an awful lot of confusion about this
whereas a double agent simply put
is an agent who is officially authorized
to commit espionage
so what that means is you hear very
often in the press that people like
ames hanson and nicholson were double
agents they're not they were agents of
the russian intelligence service
now i think one of the most neglected
aspects of world war ii by british and
american historians even today
is the war in eastern front the
historiography of the war is dominated
by
books describing and analyzing every
facet of the war in europe north africa
and asia
now the historiography of the
intelligence and counter-intelligence
war in world war
ii is also dominated largely by british
and american historians
rightfully extolling the exploits of the
special operations executive
mi5 mi6 the office of strategic services
breaking of the enigma codes and above
all descriptions and analysis
of the effectiveness of britain's double
cross committee
in fact the only synoptic treatment of
intelligence and counterintelligence of
the counter intelligence and
counterintelligence for excuse me for
any service in world war ii
was done by the british in that series
british intelligence in the second world
war which is about
six or eight volumes now the reason for
this imbalance
is largely because of sustained lack of
systematic access to primary source
material in russia over the last
50 plus years although the russians have
published literally thousands of books
and articles on world war ii
many do not meet western history graphic
standards
even today russian historians have the
same problem as westerners lack of
access
the real history of world war ii is
still politically sensitive topic for
the russian government and the security
services
and this is slowly starting to change
colonel david glance has done more than
any other american historian over the
last 30 years to systematically exploit
russian primary source material on the
war
as well as some material on soviet
military intelligence and soviet
military deception
other historians such as john erickson
omar bartoff richard ovary
albert c earl ziemke anthony b4 and the
recent monumental work by the research
institute for military history in
potsdam germany
which has devoted two huge volumes of a
10-part series to the eastern front
have provided english-speaking readers
with excellent analysis dedicated solely
to the war in the east
now many of these works also relied
heavily on german military records as
well as soviet ones
now for the intelligence and
counterintelligence war in russia
amy knight michael parish john ziak and
robert conquest
have all done excellent work on the
internal politics and have outlined the
operational history of the soviet
security services
including those in world war ii and also
we cannot forget
pavel suited plateau's memoirs he was
chief of the nkvd
that's the people's commissary for
internal affairs fourth directorate
which was special tasks
and those memoirs were edited by gerald
schechter and we also can't forget david
murphy who is a former cia officer
his upcoming book on why stalin ignored
the impending warnings of the german
attack
however portions of pseudo-plato's
memoirs aside because he does go into
some details on
agent operations in world war ii
operational counterintelligence
histories are lacking
again largely due to little or no real
sustained archival access
and nigel west i think a lot of you know
nigel west he's a prolific writer on
things intelligence and
counterintelligence nigel west in his
book crown jewels
and that book was basically about what
kim philby guy burgess and maclean all
passed to the russians
nigel weston's book crown jewels sourced
many of his details
on what the soviet intelligence service
knew about the complex max case
to classified soviet study the mata of
the material
but it's not clear if nigel himself was
able to actually have the document fully
translated
and it's not clear if the document has
been declassified as available to
researchers
this becomes pretty important i'll go
into that later but the max case
was the code name for a german agent
network in sofia with alleged sources
inside russia
and i'll go into that in detail later
because it's a very complex case but
i'll try to shorten it
and timothy naftali in an article a few
years ago
cited russian sources is telling him
that smash that's
smacked beyond him death despise soviet
military counter intelligence after
april 1943. he did a study on the max
smurfs did a study on the max case and
they could not identify
any transmitters broadcasting to sofia
or bucharest as max alleged
now these two authors as well as gerald
schechter's book on pseudoplata are
collectively responsible for bringing to
light
some of the most important russian
revelations concerning the max case to
come out in the last 50 years
now on the german side david thomas tim
mulligan david khan and heinz hernan
german author have done outstanding work
on how german intelligence viewed the
soviets
john waller in his book the unseen war
in europe has pieced together a
fascinating study of how german
intelligence subverted itself
to some extent helped by the british and
the americans
now the actual conduct of the war is in
the east is still politically sensitive
in russia
conduct of the intelligence and
counter-intelligence war is even more so
barbarous conduct of the nkbd both
before and during the war
which is well documented again by
conquest ziac knight and parish and
others
stalin's failure to put soviet forces on
full alert just before the invasion
brutal deportation of millions of soviet
citizens and the executions of hundreds
of thousands of soviet soldiers by the
nkvd for the political crimes
for political crimes and other crimes as
well remain sensitive
detailed histories of soviet
intelligence and counterintelligence
operations during the war are lacking
and the fsb and the f svr the fsb is the
russian current russian internal service
and the svr
is the current russian external service
their archives are closed to researchers
there's also no declassification system
in russia
and this hampers the advancement of
intelligence studies in russia
and to my knowledge the russians have
not declassified any of their
operational files
like we did here i mean the cia
declassified 400 000
records of the office of strategic
services not too long ago
however despite these difficulties we
can piece together
very important story and that is how the
soviets defeated the intelligence
the german intelligence service and and
also its impact on german operational
decision making
but before i go into that that brings
the question of what i used for sources
now in addition to the books and
articles i've already mentioned much of
the material resides here in the
archives
and this is key our view of soviet
counterintelligence operations during
world war ii is dependent to a large
degree
on analysis about their three records
that's german military
counterintelligence
and specifically the interrogation of
colonel heinrich schmalzlager who is
chief of
german military counter intelligence on
the eastern front
also as well as other german ci officers
now the op air 1 records that's the
german clandestine service they're the
the
human intelligence collectors their
records for the east were never really
recovered
and are probably still in russian hands
now these op air 3 records are
complemented by numerous and allied
interrogation reports of german
intelligence officers after the war
u.s military analytical studies of
german documents analysis of
fho which is from the hera aust that's
the german military
intelligence organization in the eastern
front
on studies on soviet intelligence
activities analysis of some material of
the intelligence sections of the german
army groups and armies in the east
also have an interesting document that
came out of two years ago three years
ago
it's a top secret soviet history of
their own service and it's used as
was used as a training manual for kgb
officers
that's made its way west through the
baltics and it's posted in its entirety
on one of the harvard
university cold war studies websites
the russians also published an
unclassified six volume
history of their own service well owned
foreign intelligence service
and bombs three and four deal with the
war in the east
and also the russians have published
several compendiums of declassified
documents
but the problem with a lot of this stuff
is that they're not
there's not a lot of operational detail
in them but they're still useful
and of course i also use numerous
secondary sources such as memoirs of
german and russian intelligence officers
soviet and russian histories and again
many of which don't meet western
histographic standards
now one of the questions i don't know
how many of you have studied
the war on eastern front at all or
realize how brutal it was but one of the
questions is what does
counterintelligence matter
in a war of such barbarity incompetence
and gross miscalculations
soviet german war of 1941-45 dwarfs in
size and brutality
all other theaters of world war ii with
a possible exception of japan's long war
in china
in four years of continuous combat the
war was waged on a two thousand mile
front that stretched from the arctic to
the caspian
in a climate that one german general
called a series of natural disasters
and if any of you have been to russia
you can probably sympathize with that
in other words it was waged in an area
five times the size of pre-war germany
or
in the equivalent of the entire area of
the united states from the mississippi
to the atlantic ocean
the stalin said after the war that
destruction was equivalent to an atomic
war
there were anywhere between 27 million
to 35 million
dead soviet citizens by 1945 that was
roughly about 18 percent of the
population
of about 200 million german army lost
roughly 10 million troops out of
out of which 3.5 million died that's
just on the eastern front
catastrophe was arguably for the
russians the worst since the initial
mongol invasion
and for the germans world war ii was the
worst disaster since the 30 years war
now in addition to waging the war
against the nazis stalin continued to
inflict his many holocaust on the soviet
population
this prompted one british official to
call stalin genghis khan with a
telephone
now again it brings up the question what
does counterintelligence matter in a war
of that size
i think it matters because in the
fifteen fifty major soviet offenses
the germans or 50 major soviet offensive
against the germans the soviets used
military deception
generally effectively and soviet
counterintelligence played a substantial
role
in ensuring the success of soviet moscow
which in turn played a significant role
in defeating the german army in the east
now military deception and
counterintelligence go together they're
almost inseparable in wartime
now mosquito for those of you who don't
speak russian can be generally is a
soviet umbrella term
for what generally can be called in
english or
actually a us military terminology
perception management
now the combination of soviet
counterintelligence and soviet military
deception
resulted in the germans consistently
underestimating what i would call the
soviet recuperative capacity
at the beginning of the war the germans
were surprised by a number of events
quality of soviet tanks the
extraordinary increase in the number of
soviet divisions shortly after the
invasion
and the appearance of katusha rocket
launchers all this is
fairly well known however the main
mistake
my opinion was germans underestimating
the ability of the soviet armed forces
to quickly generate
and or reconstitute combat-ready
divisions and
underestimating the scale and scope of
soviet counter-attacks at moscow
stalingrad course and the bella russian
offensive in 19
june 1944 the worst mistake
fho made was to underestimate soviet
troop strength and operation immigration
in june 1944 right about the time of
d-day
by 1.2 million men now that offensive
destroyed army group center
premier german army group on the eastern
front and it resulted in the loss of
almost 400
000 german troops in less than two
months worse than coarse and worse than
stalingrad
50 of an entire german army group gone
in two months
now the questions are of course why and
how did
the the why and how did the best german
intelligence organization in world war
ii which was fho
and the german intelligence
organizations were not very good across
the board but
this one wasn't bad how did he make such
great how did reinhardt galen
make such gross errors now in addition
to the well-documented structural
inadequacies and arrogance of german
intelligence
germans during the entire war in the
east never had a good agent or
in the jargon of counterintelligence
good penetration
of the soviet military the communist
party or the security and intelligence
services
and that's post-war reinhardt galen
claims the sign
now according to the post-war
interrogation of colonel hermann bound
who was chief of clandestine human on
the eastern front for the germans
none of his operations were successful
in fact the german agent failure rates
were as high as 90 percent
the 90 percent failure rate i think even
in combat is
fairly high i think it's so high in fact
that it raises the questions of whether
there was a soviet penetration of the
higher levels of the german intelligence
service in the east
and the russians have never discussed
this and i think this is a critical
element of the nazi soviet
counterintelligence war
and it's not been answered to date and
my own personal opinions i only think
that the russians can answer that
now what the lack of good agents really
meant for the germans
is that with soviet forces on the attack
overrunning airfields and gaining air
superiority
and with german resources stretch beyond
their limits the ability of the germans
to conduct good photo reconnaissance
diminished
and the germans were forced to rely on
signals intelligence and pow
interrogations
so in other words the german german
intelligence became in the aggregate
almost
two-thirds blind if you say the three
against fodent human and sigit
two of them are gone also
uh what contributed to was soviet
mosquito discipline
and that was enforced by soviet military
counterintelligence and draconian
security measures that strangled the
ability of german agents to operate
behind soviet lines
and in the ussr at large
now with no good window into the true
intentions of the soviets
the germans not only had no concept that
the soviets could deceive on a grand
scale
but soviet military deception had a much
greater chance of success as the germans
couldn't counter it
if you don't know it's there it's hard
to counter and here's why
having a few good having a few good
agents
or having few good agents i'm sorry put
german intelligence in the position that
any agent
regardless of quality is better than no
agent at all and if any of you worked in
any kind of a human organization i think
you can
sort of empathize with that idea
now this laid the groundwork for german
susceptibility to believing those agents
turned by the soviets
who were transmitting false true or
misleading military information
now that mix of true false or misleading
information
would depend on what soviet deception
planners wanted to pass to the germans
at any given time
now another according to retired russian
colonel dmitry tarasov he was a 35-year
veteran of state security
and chief of the smurfs section that was
responsible for coordinating
disinformation with the general staff
he wrote his memoirs soviet military
counterintelligence ran 183
radio playbacks in the entire war that
is a lot of radio playbacks and because
they're very labor intensive and demand
a lot of attention a lot of attention to
detail
now as a comparison the british in their
deception against the germans they ran
roughly 15 radio playbacks out of a
total of 39 double agents
and the germans ran about 35 radio
playbacks against the russians
now terrasso said in his memoirs that
the soviets purposely
ran double agents and radio playbacks
against the germans
with the idea of instilling confidence
in those agents
bypassing good feed material so the
germans would be predisposed to be
satisfied with what they received
and that would deter the germans from
establishing parallel agent networks
pretty interesting idea
now another reason why the germans had a
hard time uh in the east
the operational environment in the ussr
was extremely hostile i don't know if
have
any of you been to russia but it's um
fsb is a pretty nasty service
even now but the operational environment
in the ussr was extreme ussr was
extremely hostile
constant checkpoints roving patrols for
document expect inspections
country was riddled with informants
possibly as many as 22 million
informants
military ci had total control of the
immediate area behind the front
arbitrary changes in the markings on
identification papers kept the germans
on ballots
transmitters wouldn't work over long
distances differences in soap
whether buttons on underwear were
covered and the type of staples and
documents could all compromise an agent
so for example the soviets knew an agent
was working for the germans
and the agent was a soviet citizen
soviets knew an agent was working for
the germans by the fact that the agent
was issued 20 rounds for a noggin pistol
and the soviets issued 21 rounds to
their troops
so tiny error now informants were so
dense and so
in some soviet troop units there was
many like as one informant for any
10 people and depending on the
sensitivity of the unit the informant
density was even worse
this is arguably the single most
important reason why the germans had
difficulties penetrating the soviet
military
as well as other key institutions such
as the intelligence services
in fact the informant system was so
dense
and the soviets are so paranoid that
they ran informant networks against one
another to check them to make sure
they're all doing what they're supposed
to do and they do this in the middle of
a war
that was a brutal war that bore no
resemblance to the counterintelligence
operations in the cold war
so for example agent testing
to determine if the soviet pow was
served it was serious about working for
the germans
he was ordered to kill one of his fellow
pows while being photographed doing it
i don't think we'd get away with
something like that today the soviets
dropped agent teams in some cases
without parachutes into newly fallen
snow so the germans wouldn't detect the
parachutes
if one of the team members broke a leg
his partner was required to shoot him
in one case when the russians knew one
of their own asian teams had been
doubled by the germans
the booby trapped and airdropped
supplies to the team and when the german
counterintelligence
officers opened the bundle it blew up
killing the officers
and the soviets systematically
penetrated virtually all of the major
german agent training schools
in some cases the soviets were running
running training instructors
who gave soviet counterintelligence
advance warning of agent deployments
before i go into this exam this got so
brazen that some of these soviet agents
would actually use radios inside some of
these german agent training
training centers to transmit to their
soviet controllers
now for example from july to december
1942
two soviet agents and two different
german training schools
provided the soviets with information on
200 op-air agents
to include photos information on code
books targets and deployment schedules
and many soviet agents and german
training schools were responsible for
large-scale
defections of german agents
now the mass of soviet agents aided by
the partisans overwhelmed german
counterintelligence and this put german
counterintelligence on the defensive for
almost the whole war
colonel heinrich schmalzleger said that
through analysis of soviet agent
deployments his organization could
predict weeks in advance
soviet offenses it's a standard
counterintelligence tactic you can try
to do that
now he said that he could predict weeks
in advanced soviet offensives
while that might be true as far as it
goes the soviets purposely increased
agent deployments in places
as diversions and when huge formations
plan for offensive operations that
fact is difficult to hide i mean if
you're talking about a million men it's
very difficult to hide if you want them
to attack
however the size and scope of attack can
be hidden and schmall schleger makes no
mention of whether he was able through
analysis of soviet agent deployments to
predict the strength and magnitude of
soviet offenses or soviet counter
attacks
now as radio playbacks were key channels
for soviet disinformation
and as they were the only way at that
time to rapidly transmit controlled
information to the enemy
i'd like to give some brief examples of
the effectiveness of those radio
playbacks
now of course in 1943 the soviets
employed nine radio transmitters
and according to soviet sources they
used all captured
german agents that were doubled to
transmit disinformation
transmitters were located in livna
stugra castorney and tambolf
transmitters confirmed each other's
information
some went off the air under non-alerting
pretext so that the nazis could not
verify information
transmitters as far away as moscow surat
off and pence
carefully cooperated information from
the transmitters in an around course
messages on some transmitters were sent
every two to three days
disinformation reinforced the idea
that the soviets would stay on the
defensive agents reported on the
shipments of barbed wire
the digging of anti-tank ditches and
construction of bunkers
the soviets tried to keep reporting on
troop movements to a minimum
soviet double agent alexander demianov
that i'll get into soon
known as max supplied the germans with
information at soviet reserves to the
north
and south of the course assailant lacked
maneuverability
and these operations of course were
centrally controlled
now the result was a gross
underestimation of the strength of
soviet counter-attacks despite
stiff german resistance and heavy soviet
casualties by august 1943 the russians
had captured biela gorad
oriol harkoff and brian which is what
they intended to do to start with
now immigration in the summer of 1944
there were numerous german agents who
were captured and doubled
at least three radio playbacks were used
that we know of
probably more and a combination of
soviet moscow
discipline lack of german aircraft
soviet radio silence
and inability of german agents to move
around the rear area of the soviet army
resulted in the following gala not
detecting the presence of three combined
arms armies
several mobile cores and a tank army he
underestimated not only the main weight
of the soviet offensive but
underestimated soviet
strength by one million two hundred and
thirty thousand men and german army
group center
was destroyed in less than two months
now before i close here i want to make a
few comments on two interrelated and
highly complex but controversial
operations
this gets kind of confusing i understand
that so hopefully
it's not that confusing now one is known
to the soviets as operation monastery
and that's chapter six in the book
and his this key personality in this
operation was alexander dimianov code
named haina by the russians
and he was codenamed max by the germans
now it's clear from german documentation
pseudoplatas memoirs and other russian
sources that haina or demyanov
was operating in and around moscow
against german army group center
and that he used the used name alexander
as traffic with the germans
now the other operation also known as
max
was run by the op by ab verstella vienna
and the agent was richard calder
alias clot counter clock he operated out
of sofia and bucharest
or maybe budapest anyway one of the two
cities now case clot has brie
has baffled counterintelligence officers
for more than 50 years and continues to
do so
russians for more than half a century oh
i'm sorry the russians have not come
entirely clean with their involvement
with clot
even though they interrogated this
mistress and tried to kidnap him twice
after the war
now my contention is that while we have
two different operations both with the
same german code name
they were connected in moscow and the
feed material for both was coordinated
by the soviet general staff
klotz channeled to the germans went
straight from vienna to the eastern
front
and while clotte himself was a notorious
swindler and a liar
the channel was used by the russians in
my opinion to pass controlled
information at least some of the time
now according to nigel west's research
the russians knew through
kim philby and others through kim philby
and others giving them british decrypts
of summer clots traffic
that he was highly valued by the germans
now based primarily on information
gleaned from numerous numerous
interrogations after the war by
allied ci officers clot was a jewish
agent of the art fair he set up an
alleged network of agents inside russia
which would report on a wide variety of
military topics and he did it with the
help of anton turkles intel
intelligence chief ira longin now turkle
was a soviet immigrant
ahead of a soviet immigrant organization
for a very long time
and ira longing was the chief of
intelligence they were both suspected of
being soviet agents i don't know that it
was ever solidly proven
then interrogations of both clot and
longin the allied interrogators
determined these alleged sources were
notional
so he made it all up germans had serious
doubts about clots reliability during
the war
he survived several investigations but
the germans continued to run him anyway
because heinz guderian said
he could not live without his reporting
and the germans thought they could
distinguish between his false and real
information
even though there were so many
counterintelligence indicators when they
were running this case that he was no
good
clot and his associates had several
contacts inside the legation in sophia
including at least two soviet
intelligence officers
now the most pa perplexing question even
today was how klot
received his information that still has
not been 100 percent determined
as the text of klotz messages has been
not been made public
and there were apparently four thousand
he claims a whole lot more
we can only guess but in my opinion what
the soviets did was they securely
radioed feed material to the soviet
legation in sofia had long under
somebody else pick it up
and give it to clot
long and his girlfriend and summer klotz
associates were at one time or another
seen in the company of soviet
intelligence officers are seen going
into the legation
this channel was my opinion too tempting
for the soviets not to use
and also there are uncanny similarities
in the stories used to justify klotz
notional sources inside russia
and demianov's stated position
and they're all radio operators or work
in military communications centers of
some kind
and i think that similarity is too
uncanny in other words long and didn't
make all of this up didn't get it all
out of the newspapers
now between monastery and clot the
following is an example of what was
provided to the germans
pseudoplato stated that monastery was
one of the most
one of the most if not the most
effective soviet deception of the war
because be shortly shortly before
stalingrad demianov
correctly predicted the soviets would
attack army groups center in the area of
richoff and in the north caucasus and
south leningrad
now the germans reinforced army group
center with 12 divisions largely based
on that information
galen assessed as late as 12 november
that the soviets did not have enough
strength to attack in the vicinity of
stalingrad of course
and they did attack with 1 million 140
000 troops on 19 november
now this is extremely important
effectively what this did was what
demianov did was tip the germans off
under orders to an offensive by zhukov
against army group center
so zhukov attacks like he's supposed to
and in
in that process i think because to some
extent because of the tip-off shoe golf
lost 760 000 men in less than two months
and i think it was done and this is
arguable it was done to preserve
stalingrad offensive stalingrad
offensive
was pretty quick and they captured 250
000 german troops
i'm sorry 108 thousand german troops by
the time they surrendered
now demianov uh during immigration
reported on a high-level conference
i'm sorry progressions the soviet yellow
russian defensive in june 1944
against army group center now he
reported on a high-level conference in
which two plans were considered
to attack in the direction of brest
latoff scored a conducting offensive
against army group south ukraine towards
the balkans
so demiano said that stalin decided on
the latter
well on june 13th galen assessed that
the main soviet offensive would take
place in the south
on 23 june 2 million four hundred
thousand soviet troops began the
destruction of soviet army group center
and in a month and a half the germans
lost four hundred thousand men
now with clot his reporting is very
similar to demianos
so to summarize quickly intelligence and
counterintelligence war in the east was
enormous in scope
complex and despite its brutality and
inefficiency at times highly
sophisticated especially towards the end
of the war
but there are numerous questions this
book does not pretend to be the
definitive work on soviet
counterintelligence in world war
ii and there's too many questions to be
asked to still be answered
and here are the following questions i
think that really need to be answered
did the soviets have an agent or agents
and fho
as well as in the german army high
command okh
and if so who were they and how would
they run now it's interesting the head
of the
colonel bound who was headed the um op
air one on the eastern front was
investigated by the us army
counterintelligence corps at the end of
the war for being a soviet agent because
he was turned in by some of the agents
that he ran
as being a soviet spy now cic never
found anything
but i think it's interesting that they
focused on him
now did the soviets break any german
intelligence codes i don't think the
soviets have ever admitted that they did
what was the soviet role in the counter
cloud affair i don't think that's ever
been made clear
why was demianoff ostensibly so
successful and why is he the only double
agent this
agent the soviets talk about in any
detail
now the fact that these key questions
remain not only demonstrates the russian
pension for secrecy but also the never
ending complexities of the largest
counter-intelligence war in history
thank you very much and does anybody
have any questions
hey we will take questions from the
audience i'll just
remind you folks that the views of dr
seven do not represent the views of the
united states government
mine on the other hand let's start yes
stephen
to what extent did the soviets make use
of
members of a common turn for espionage
especially in occupied europe
i think the short answer is yes they did
okay but i don't know to what extent
um anthony
k brown wrote a book on that call i
think called the red
i forgot i read it so long ago but it's
good
no no it's called it's a book on the
common turn
it's huge it's like encyclopedia but the
short answer is
yes they did and i don't know
unfortunately yes sir
please talk about leopold trepper and
the royal cuphead
and how about the revelation that
reinhard galen
was a communist agent why didn't i
wasn't aware
let me back up on the road to what i
focused on when i did this i didn't talk
about it in here but what i focused on
when i did this was the russian
the russian uh agents who were in
intelligence organizations within the
road to cappella
of boyzone was one a guy named golinov
was another
and two or three others that i don't
remember off the top of my head but
that whole organization i mean i mean
especially the luftwaffe and the
luftwaffe intelligence was penetrated
from one end to the other they had a
great deal of information on
you know german war plans on when the
attack would come
german troop dispositions and i think
they had it even
after the war started for a while until
the germans rolled the network up
but i think it was extremely important
in in but what they what they did what
these
i think what these agents didn't have
necessarily was access to information on
german agents in the east
i wanted to point out if you folks look
in your schedule this time next week
we're going to be having a panel
discussion
discussing galen we're going to have uh
ken mcdonald former g historian of the
cia
richard myers an archivist from the
national archives as well as tim
naftali uh who actually used some of his
uh yes
works uh he's gonna we're gonna be here
discussing united states intelligence in
germany
after world war ii so you could say this
is kind of a follow-up i don't mean
i don't mean to short-change your
question because that organization was
extremely important
and you know for example i mean not
reinhard galen so much
that i'm aware of but hans oster was
suspected in the cia study on the road
to capela possibly being a soviet agent
and several other high level up fair
officers a lot of them close to canaris
yes so a simple
explanation for why stalin ignored
indications of the impending invasion
of my troops that is an excellent
question and i'm not totally qualified
to answer it
certainly dave murphy is a few others
but i'll try the best i can
stalin was operating on a different
frequency than the people that he was
um that were around him and
i think he he really believed that
hitler wouldn't do it
there's a new book that just came out by
a guy named british author named
montefiore called
stalin the court of the redzar and
i heard montefiore on booknotes not too
long ago and he's an impressive guy
but they've got some very inter intimate
portraits of stalin's entourage
and stalin after the war i think told
somebody in in one of those
rare moments of candor that i didn't
something to the effect of i didn't
believe hitler would do it
so let's go with dave rogers a lot of
the
intelligence spy literature is highly
contentious
uh nigel west for instance is a
pseudonym
and he doesn't seem to document a great
deal so
how reliable can you can you
evaluate west as uh as an as an
authority
how how does he how what is his
reliability okay do you mean this
reliability on this particular issue
that i was
in this particular issue in any issue
because like david wise
he's always cranking out books and
and then and when you crank out that
many books i get very suspicious
well i understand your concern
definitely do
i think you can i think the short answer
is nigel west is probably
reasonably reliable i mean but it
depends on how you evaluate it i think
if you
you read these books for avenues for
further historical inquiry
i think they're pretty useful and of
course west has got sources that
sometimes don't lend themselves
necessarily to a lot of footnotes
you know so i think you have to use them
but you know use them with other people
as well
and um in this particular case i looked
at his footnotes i read his chapter on
that max case like five times because
it's such a complicated case
he has got a lot of information in there
a lot of very interesting information
and it's pretty clear that that soviet
document that he was talking about
somebody read it
somebody took good notes on but the
problem is is that you don't know
anything else about the document you
don't really know you know the headings
and the footers and
you know you don't get a feel for you
know what i'm talking you worked in the
archive so you know what i mean you
don't get a feel for the document itself
i also worked with yeah dr lohan
um two of the sources of dissent in
germany
uh might have been socialists and
communists and of course uh
people connected with jews or who didn't
approve of the final solution
and i wonder if if those were two groups
that uh
the russians uh recruited in their
counter spy network
yeah i think they did because what were
those in equal proportions or what
proportion well i think an awful lot of
the road to capella are certainly the
the people i was honing in on because
it's a huge organization i mean they had
like what i don't know
uh i think um john costello
in his book deadly illusions talks about
there's like something like 400 agents
in that network
roughly now that may not not be an
accurate number but it was big
and i think the ones i focused on i
think they were partly socialist and
communist and also very
anti-hitler sometimes that goes hand in
hand and it's hard to separate
um
at the end of the war nearly in the war
like the summer of 1944
even if the germans had good
intelligence uh would have made much of
a difference
that's a very good question and i
thought a lot about that
and i think in the conclusion of the
book
basically i think if the germans had
better intelligence
it might have been assuming that okh and
hitler and everybody else would act on
it
okay it might have slowed down the
soviet advance
but the biggest mistake the germans made
i think in their intel
i think when you analyze all of this the
biggest single mistake the germans made
outside of june 44 was in the
pre-invasion intelligence assessments of
the soviet union
and the biggest problem that they had
was they didn't really understand how
the soviets could generate combat ready
divisions quickly
now if you um i'm taking a long time to
answer your question
if um
if the mistake was at the beginning of
the war and the germans never ever
recovered from it for example by april
42 i mean they were down four or five
six hundred thousand troops that were
never replaced
so if the mistake is made in the
beginning of the war then all the other
mistakes kind of pile on i mean galen
didn't take over this job until like
april 42.
and i think it's not that it was four
day and the germans would lose
but there was certainly some very
significant uh errors they made in the
beginning and then they're all piled on
so i think by the middle of the war even
if they had had better intelligence
they probably would have slowed down the
soviet advance i don't know that they
could have won the war with it
carl the
russians of course had very good
intelligence in this country
and they had a lot of information that
went back to russia
the winona files talked about this my
understanding is that those files have
never been completely decoded and that
there are hundreds of names
of soviet spies in this country people
who were never identified and never
caught do you know whether any effort is
going on within the cia or anyplace else
in the government
to continue to try to decode
these files and to find these people
and at least identify them as far as i
know
no i don't think that there is and i
think you're right about there's
hundreds of people in those winona
decrypts that that i think
based on the analysis of how the soviets
communicated
are in a clandestine relationship with
the soviets
okay that's important because you can
have lots of names in an intercept and
they can be encrypted but
you don't know what kind of relationship
that they're in but i think the people
that i talked to that i've heard
brief on this subject have said yeah
there's an awful lot in those files
that um that they know we're in
clandestine relationships with the
soviets
yeah and i think it's kind of
unfortunate that probably no idea why
nothing is being done
you know i think
the reason probably is just resources
you know i mean it takes a long time to
do that that was not an easy thing to do
i mean it took him a long time after the
war and i think
was it lamphere's book one of the books
actually said that
they stopped it in the mid was it mid
80s
i know somewhere in there because
because it wasn't producing much
so even though they got a lot i mean
it's still a very difficult process to
do that
so final questions going once
going twice yes sir
do you know what happened to leopold
trepper after the war
i personally don't and i should um
i forgot
he was taken to moscow
stalin imprisoned him for 16 years
they then inexplicably released him
he went to israel and
interim he went to london for a while
but he died in israel
and his memoirs are there
but they are inaccessible
i tried to get them oh that's too bad
that is really too bad
well i'm going to ask the last question
the last question that doctor what's
next
i don't know well then i'll tell you
what then i do want to invite you to
come back to the national archives uh to
speak but ladies and gentlemen
dr robert steffen thank you very much
thank you i'd like to thank the
university press of kansas i'd like to
thank book tv and also for you for
coming
uh if you'll walk outside with us dr
stefan will be signing copies of his
book
my colleague volunteers will be showing
you where the rotunda is
so if those of you like to see the
declaration and the constitution the
charge of freedom may do so
thank you all very much for coming and
we hope to see you back here at the
archive soon
thanks well done thanks
robert stefan works for the central
intelligence agency
with the specialization in russian
intelligence stalin's secret war
is published by university press of
kansas on the web at
kansaspress.ku.edu